usually people cry while they tell their
stories not before they start yeah well
am I still going
where are you from where'd you grow up
I grew up in Hawthorne California
South Bay Area yep tell me about your
family growing up growing up yeah my my
mom and dad they were real
conservative middle class Mexican family
and um my dad worked at a um a paper
machine factory yeah Paper Mill and my
mother she was born in Mexico
um
she's just
a girl from Mexico
how did you describe your childhood my
childhood um there's four of us um I got
one brother and three sisters I mean two
sisters
um
it was a it was okay very strict
conservative family you know would go to
school come home
um
I was a little bit different from mice
for my sisters and brothers I I wanted
to
I wanted to live quick you know I just
I wanted to have fun and not follow the
rules
you know but um
hey you know the black sheep of your
family yeah
to say the least uh
what kind of kid were you in high school
not that great
um
went to school
it didn't really go to went to school
got average grades but um when I hit
High School
funds
you know it wasn't about to date
sorry a minute ago you know my first
first love
and um
it would couldn't date so um
summer school you know we had to go to
school because I didn't go to school
period you know but sign my mom's got
straight UPS
and um
we started seeing each other and uh
then um
my appearance found out they sent me to
Mexico
I was supposed to be there for a year
and um
I was really hard for me to you know
milk cows and uh
do all that kind of stuff so
you know um
I stayed there three months I didn't
stay there a whole year
because
um
you know I
told him that they wouldn't send me back
home I'd cut my wrists
so they sent me back home
and I came back and then I
continue you know with my with my
apparently came across at my the guy
that I was seeing and we've seen each
other and then I got pregnant
I tried to hide it from my mom
16. and um she told me I had to tell my
dad and I couldn't tell my dad so snuck
out that window
you're growing up do you know how to be
a grown-up period not know how to be a
grown-up and I snuck out of the window
and um
there we had my first daughter
yeah he was Colombian he's Colombian
and um he had a little girl and it was
Nikki
foreign
after I had her you know still was with
my um
with my boyfriend you know we stayed
together
stayed 16 years to do I stayed with him
but um wasn't very easy
wasn't easy at all
with him
three
he became real abusive
excuse me
I didn't want to go back
being the promise to my mom dad
she's like stayed with him until you
know back and forth
he abused me for it
quite a while
ended up in a women's shelter
put it
I talk to you
and I came back
came back with him
went back with him
I ended up having two more kids
Aaron and Marcus
you know
stayed with him and then um
finally stood up by myself told him I
didn't want to be with him anymore
and um
drink a lot
let's try it out that
because he cheated on me a lot
so
whatever
he's building up I was sleeping one day
and my
first my my I kept trying to keep my
kids with me and
um
they want to play across the street with
my um friend and um well
they tried to crack you know she tried
to crack through her 11 and 11 and 12
you know so I went hysterical and I
called my father and I told him to you
can take my kids you know for a minute
till I get through this with my husband
you know who was smoking crack huh who
was smoking crackers no I was doing
methamphetamine me I was doing
masturbating my daughter she was playing
across the street and
she had tasted it you know tasted it
didn't know what it was correct yeah but
I would you know
yeah oh I found out you know so I told
my father and tell him to come pick him
up and so he picked him up
and she just tasted it okay she was she
was okay you know
but I knew I couldn't you know I'm going
through this
abusive relationship and can't
you know my daughter's taste you know
it's like
I wanted I wanted her to be okay so she
went with my parents and then I stayed
with my just my little boy okay well
when I was sleeping he crawled out the
window
and went to my neighbor my neighbor
which was my aunt
asked for a cookie
she didn't wake me up she called my mom
instead of waking me up
and they you know I'm running up and
down the street looking for my kid and
uh
when um she said why don't you call your
mom I called my mom she came and she
said yeah I had I had Marcus and I said
okay great um
the next day Social Services over my
house
because my little sister called Social
Services on me
they didn't see the picture
crying out for help
social worker tells my dad is suitable
for us to stay there
can your daughter and your grandson stay
with you and he said there's room for
for my grandson but not room for my
daughter
so he
and then my daughter my son
take my son
and I say to my home where I lost my
children my husband
nothing
and where'd your daughter go
sorry excuse me [__]
worker told me
I'm so sorry she looked down at the
floor She says I'm so sorry
I left
yeah me too
so
that night I drank the rest of the night
my vodka because I had nothing on my
kids
nothing
and I sat in the middle of the street on
Prairie
Prairie and El Segundo
waiting for a car to hit me
here comes a Volkswagen bus I swears
misses me
the guy comes jumps out of the car it
was a friend of mine and my husband's
actually
he didn't know that it was me
and uh
he says what the [__] get out the street
and then he said John and he picks me up
puts me in the car tells me what the
[__] are you doing
why why the [__] are you trying to kill
yourself
and let your kids think that you don't
love him enough stick it out
then he drops me off
I come back home
thank you you know what [__]
he's right
he's right absolutely right
[__] yeah I'm not gonna give up so get
on with my life a little bit you know
nine months later he keeps coming over
you know to check on me
well
we end up together
me and him my ex sons are a good friend
it was a good friend of his
seven years I mean seven babies later
got seven kids together he's a Cuban
Cuban from Cuba May rest in peace
we end up having 10 babies some
beautiful babies
awesome kids
but we struggle you know
we struggle he's a Cuban rapid you know
doesn't have no papers you know he does
Rock smokes Rock
um
and I do math and so you know I don't do
it rot do math he stopped doing Rock
because I no no no I couldn't can handle
him so he does meth with me we end up
smoking meth but raising our kids as
best way we know how okay not very good
the First with one or two kids that you
lost early on uh no the three stayed
with my parents but I continued to go
see my kids you know I was a good mom
okay first and believe okay I did
I I did drugs okay yes I did but I was a
good mom from under the circumstances of
how what life ditched out to me the day
I crawled out the window you know
didn't want to face my parents you know
I was a good Mama the best way I knew
how you know nobody gives you a book on
how to be a parent
you should learn how to be a mama you
know back to your childhood was there
any abuse in your childhood my dad was
very strict very very you know that's
why I got pregnant okay if you wouldn't
let me go out and see a boy you know but
he didn't you know he was very strict he
sent me to Mexico
to keep me away from him yeah I
understand you know come on now you
didn't send me in Mexico you know where
I don't know how to speak Spanish
I live in a [__] you know house with
no there's no roof over it you got to go
outside to go to the bathroom when I
live in in California
I'm a surfer girl
you tell me how would I do
not very good
learn to talk in Spanish you know with
all Mexican people okay no no no not
very easy not very good okay so my
upbringing was very hard
very hard difficult difficult difficult
difficult okay not to say the least okay
the only mistake I made in my life was
to fall in love
you know that's it
the rest okay I did the best I could
when I crawled out that window to take
care of my kids the best way I knew how
because [__] don't crucify me don't put
me up against it you know what I mean
no come on now
it's the only thing I did wrong
[__] fall in love
now the choices I made were mine
you know doing drugs and stuff yeah
well hey
don't send me your New Mexico to the
[__] milk cows and [__] you know
to keep you away from the boy you love
because guess what will happen you end
up having a whole bunch more ten I ended
up having 10 kids okay
10 kids okay oh just two men okay my
first husband my second one you raised
what's this most of those kids yes most
yes I did
yes I did they're beautiful children if
you would see my children they're
beautiful children
but the world [__] sits when you're a
woman
and you pick the men that you pick okay
when you follow the abuse of of being
controlled you know my father controlled
my mama
therefore she I learned from my mama you
know I mirrored my mama okay
I mirrored her
to try to be the best mom I could be
but I picked two men one was an abusive
[__] from Colombia
and the other one was from Cuba okay
yeah I know how to pick him no
okay no
but I learned and I [__]
put my mind
never mind I never I did it myself dust
off my [__] knees and try try again
to sum up try try again chill I'm right
here right now right here interviewed
okay
my husband got covered
we all got code
I spent 23 years with that man 23 years
23 years raising my children
just get the
I raised 15 years I lived in the whole
we rented a room from care you would
never believe it but my ex
my ex-husband's girlfriend
okay
the one
when he went to hit me okay he had a
girlfriend okay
yeah but he took uh he went home okay he
had a girlfriend but you know he didn't
love her he loved me
I didn't know he loved me routine for
five years before we got together okay I
did not know that okay
and so when one day when we we
you know I was drinking at home you know
I kissed him you know
I kissed him and um
he ran out the door he didn't come back
for three days you know I'm like oh my
God you know I made a mistake I was
drunk you know I kissed him he had a
girlfriend you know he told his
girlfriend to go back home [__] I kissed
him one time
it's one time told her to go back home
and he came home three days I came over
with bouquet of roses and a diamond ring
marry me what the [__]
to marry you
I'll take the flowers when I take that
right
I can take the ring
me so much I didn't even know it that's
all one kiss
had a ring flowers marry me wow I love
you baby
now I'm doing this all by myself
because we got him
he did two years ago
my youngest child is 17.
he's 17.
how long you been homeless for
foreign
motorhome okay at the motorhome I've
been at a model I we when we got copied
okay
I was 15 years
on 120th and Hawthorne Boulevard okay I
raised my children there
they went to school right raised my
children there
we did okay you know did okay
before I got covered
um my roommate the one that rented us
the room you know where we raised our
kids because she had a baby
she had a baby too
that's two weeks
two weeks oh young wait two weeks
younger than my daughter
they're both same father okay
because when when you know I was seeing
my husband okay
um
she moved back home and said that she
wasn't going to give up on her
relationship with him you know
but we were already seeing each other
but she found out and she came to me you
know
she caught us caught us it wasn't caught
because she told her to go home okay she
wanted to fight for him she got on our
knees and begged me to leave him alone
okay so I did I did but okay go home and
try to work it out with her I Didn't
Know I Was Pregnant already okay
so
I told him I never want to see you again
I told him to try to work it out with
her six years she was with him okay I
bowed out okay
well in those two weeks she got pregnant
but I was already pregnant
okay he came back to me and said I can't
I don't I don't love her okay I Didn't
Know I Was Pregnant at the time so we
get back together
oh wow
I'm gonna say okay she ends up having a
baby Noah
Noah
and I ended up having a baby
Elisa okay
he stays with me because he loves me
you can't keep a man
who doesn't love you not even if you
have a baby okay but he got a baby and I
would not keep any child from their
father so therefore I let him keep
seeing you know seeing his son okay so
they do we end up being friends me and
the mother so I end up we end up moving
in with her so my child
her children and her child can be raised
in the same home we raise brothers and
sisters together
you know yeah they did on 120th
we raised our children in the same home
she knew her place he loved me
but the children don't have to suffer
for that okay
if you receive my children they're
beautiful babies beautiful kids my my
you know
I had one right after another okay seven
because I get blood clots
I couldn't take birth control
okay I took birth control I ended up in
the hospital foreign
pulmonary embolism okay I had three
survived it yes indeed
yeah because I'm a Survivor not a victim
not a victim
a survivor
three permanent universities okay raise
our kids best way I knew how with my
Cuban
you know
they're awesome
covered
that's the [__] okay
drugs and alcohol too you know what I
mean okay you do our best okay you know
I'm still an addict okay trying my
hardest not to be
but life keeps dishing them out to me
teaching it out to me I'm human I'm 55
I'm 55.
I had 10 kids
my husband dies
we get a place
it's condemned but we didn't know it was
condemned
when we got the place because we're you
know EDD you know good thing
we got kicked out because my roommate
gets forty thousand dollars to re get
relocated so we end up homeless
kicked out into the street okay me and
my husband and my kids my well four at
that time okay
okay this was just
yeah I always
when we got kicked out I was 52 years
old okay
I'm 55.
okay
yeah
55.
we go to hotel
I used to clean houses
this man that I cleaned this house for
let me let I told my husband he's got a
he'll rent us his place you know
he's from
I don't know he's Middle Eastern some
India or whatever okay yeah
yeah my husband pays him three thousand
dollars to move into his this invested
[__] home excuse my language
where we catch we catch covet there okay
it's rat infested it's condemned it's
condemned though place is condemned but
we're already there okay
telling you my son killed
17 or I mean no seven rats humongous
rats like this
I okay
mind you you know that it was condemned
okay
because we're going to get into the
place we don't have money okay so we go
to there okay
big mistake
okay
because the man
son
we're abusing the man okay I see him get
hit by the man okay
so I go to court to get a restraining
order for him I mean he goes to court
asked me to testify that did he hit him
I do I go to court because I'm a good
person I do okay I do
yes I do
they got a receiver
but he's fighting on court to take the
property okay
well I'm there my husband ends up
passing away
actually tried to get him to go to the
hospital three times three to three
hospitals okay
okay I survived it
he's from Cuba
and survive it
okay he's from Cuba he didn't survive it
I survived it he was sent home I don't
know how possibly do you send somebody
home that has covered you tell me you
tell me how okay but he was sent home
okay me and my children tried to take
him to go to the hospital three times
three times
before he takes my medicine because he
didn't listen to me
he took my medicine I have a high blood
pressure
diabetes
that he would get better
when I'm taking my daughter okay because
that's okay I have my two daughters and
me okay and my two sons they stay home
with him
okay I tell him
I don't baby I'll see you at the
hospital please listen to listen to
the boys okay they're only
they're only
thank you they're 22.
and 2 21 right now okay
so this happened three years ago
when I go with my girls because my
daughter's tonsils are humongous
to take her to the hospital
I hope okay
we go to a hotel
to sleep because I'm tired because I
just got out of the hospital with covert
okay here we go
and the ambulance comes I hear the
ambulance I said I bet you this for your
daddy
and my daughter goes no it's not mama
no it's not mama
oh
but it was
the hospital
my
son and my daughter they do fennel
hell
yeah
I was supposed to be a tattoo
cracker jacker me me that's what I call
myself Cracker Jack girl
who wouldn't be Cracker Jacks
after what was just out to me okay me Me
Myself and I
um
so my daughter my son they're on the
streets
okay
she's only 19. he's 22.
because Fitness got them
Sherm has me
because I can't handle so you're using
PCP now instead of crystal meth I use
crystal methamp MP3 would you think I
wouldn't I don't know okay
with everything that's been being dished
out to me with harpoons
to me and I'm still standing yes indeed
I'm here in this interview with you
still being shot darts my my 20 year old
son who bought me my motorhome
I'm homeless it's a motorhome between 21
year old son Batman
you bought it for me
before he bought it for me he tried
killing himself when his daddy died
um
trick
m30s
took seven
and nine Xanaxes okay
when I told him when he wanted to take
his car back from his brother
yeah
be careful what you say to your children
because they might just try killing
themselves
okay
I said I'm gonna go get your car back
you can't take a gift back from your
brother
I'm disappointed and you said so would
your father be when I went to go walk
to go get his car back my son took all
those pills
yeah
because I said it was just I was
disappointed in him I'm not disappointed
you're not a disappointment son life is
going to bring you disappointments don't
try to kill yourself my God
my God
oh my God
yeah
yeah yeah that's what happened to me
how are you surviving now I'm still at
that damn motor home
what do you do for money
I'm on gr or no Cal Works my daughter I
will not bring her to that motorhome
he's staying with their best friends
mother and family okay until we I get a
place
until I get a place
okay but [__] stay in line how
am I going to get a place if you keep
throwing darts at me
because I'm cracking lacking
crack-a-lackin
smoking sure
because I can't handle it okay I can't
handle it yes indeed I can't handle it
it's too much for me
because it's too much for me it's too
much for me what's your biggest fear
right now
my biggest fear is not getting it
together
I was just tattoo of me right here
Cracker Jack girl
haha
it's not finished why because I'm in the
street
crack the head not focusing on what I
need to be focusing on because I'm a
damn good mother but get
suicide to Father husband come on with
it if your husband hadn't passed away
from kovid
my husband my son tried to commit
suicide my two kids are on fentanyl now
you think your situation would be very
different if your husband had not passed
away
if the faithful day that we were kicked
out of our home
and the events that happened the way
they happened
no hell no my husband I was there 15
years
15 years he was working
he was a mechanic
he was an excellent mechanic but he had
papers you know
so he did the best we could what other
means that we had two drug addicts
trying to raise their kids drug addicts
okay not very good combination
yeah yeah yeah but we would have did it
hell yeah 15 years in the same home hell
yeah if we were to hear from covid and
and and and and you got it together but
no no no no no no
it's hard
I'm a single woman
in a shark pool with 10 kids
okay
for at the time when my husband passed
but it's a shark pool out there
I'm a guppy
in a shark pool
being swallowed
he swallowed
because I would never think that I would
sell my ass
to see afloat that's what you do now no
I did one time
then my God totally get it together
Yolanda
don't do that
I got 10 beautiful kids how can they
follow in my footsteps if I start doing
that right
so here I am
trying to survive
trying to survive in a [__] [__] up
world
you tell me what do I do
if I can't get it together
I'm trying my hardest
I need some help
I need some help God help me because uh
my parents my mom makes you rest in
peace she's in heaven my dad's still
trying to crucify me
get me 40 when my husband died 40
dollars when my mom died he gave my
inheritance to my little sister yes
indeed because I'm a drug addict
and I fell in love went out that window
faithful day yes indeed you tell me you
tell me
what do I got to do
I'm here
because I
pretty soon my kids are going to have to
feed me with the spoon
because guess what when my son tried
committing suicide
I told him don't don't give up son life
is going to bring your love a lot of
disappointments you better put your
pants on and be a man
okay as he does goes to school I mean
goes to work has a girlfriend
you know but he's only 21. he's a baby I
don't want him to [__] think about me
and try to take care of me no he's
barely learning how to take care of
himself
just keep doing going to work going to
school and going to work and be a good
boy be a good boy and he will because if
he does drugs look at me your mama
you're gonna end up like me
a [__] basket case
yes indeed that's it that's all folks
and
all right thank you Yvonne